توصل تركيا اشهار عمليهها العسكريه التي
اسميتها المخلب السيف في وجه المسلحين
الاكراد شمال سوريا والعراق حيث قصفت
المدفعيه والمسيرات التركيه عده مواقع
لقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في عده مناطق
كتلرفعه وعين عيسى ومحيط مدينه عين العرب
كوباني غاره تعد تمهيد حسب انقره لعمليات
عسكريه واسعه نطاق ضد المسلحين الاكراد اذ
توعد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في
المرحله المقبله بمشاركه القوات البريه ضد
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
حلقنا بطائراتنا ومسيراتنا فوق الارهابيين
خلال عده ايام وان شاء الله في القريب
العاجل سنقضي عليهم جميعا بدباباتنا
وجنودنا وكل من يقاتلون الى جنبنا
لكن روسيا المتحالفه مع دمشق تخشى انفجار
الوضع في هذه المناطق الكريم قال انه
يتفهم ما يسميه بالمخاوف المشروعه لتركيا
بشان سوريا لكنه قال حسب المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه الروسيه انه يتعين على جميع
الاطراف ان تتجنب الخطوات التي قد تؤدي
الى تدهور الوضع وبعد ان دعى تركيا
الولايات المتحده الى وقف دعمها لفصائل
مسلحه كرديه حذرت واشنطن من جهتها من اي
تحرك عسكري قد يزعزع الاستقرار في هذه
المناطق